Steve Mariucci back here on the show how
you doing mooch I was listening to your
rant before the break all right doing
good all right so what do you think
about that Steve do you want to laugh
right now oh I guess I get up this
morning
and I get a text from a friend in fact
you saw him he came into the studio Pat
Morris yeah
Pat Morris has been an offensive line
coach in college and then the pros for a
long time very good coach he was in
their studio the other a couple weeks
ago he texted me happy anniversary you
know what he meant happy anniversary of
the day we got fired in Detroit mm-hmm
and and he attired another coach Andy
Sugarman all got fired after
Thanksgiving Day all right and so what's
my point my point is this but the
coaching profession you know not every
coaching situation is like Nick Saban's
at Alabama all right and you never know
you never know when you're going to get
whacked you just don't in that weekend
you know it's Thanksgiving weekend we
kidded about it during the show on
gameday morning right
we were lions are four and six entering
into Thanksgiving game and Michael Vick
and boys lead us and then I got fired so
you never know so essentially when even
if you're winning winning or losing
you're always in some way kind of a free
agent like players and the pros are kind
of like free agents you know when
they're a free agent you get to pick and
choose where you go and if you stay or
not rich I got fired from the 49ers
after winning the division and going to
the second round of the playoffs and the
year before that we're 12 in four you
don't know when you're going to get
fired
so some of these coaches got fired this
weekend but you got low and leaving and
taking the Florida job sometimes you
just got to take care of your your
family your your profession your career
when there's some possible stability in
your in your life and do it I get it
where you're leaving your kids behind
you know the kids you recruit
but it happened by Tyrone Willingham
left Stanford and went to Notre Dame
because it was a better job for him more
money and all that kind of stuff and
that's just one example of many but yeah
it's a crazy time of year it's I don't
know if there's a good answer to all of
this but the tough life you know
coaching you know there's no stability
in it whatsoever what was it like
leaving Kellogg when you left Cal for
the Niners I mean that's kind of a
no-brainer I understand that greater but
believe me rich I got I got so much hate
mail so much hate mail from the from Cal
fans and boosters because I was only
there a year left the packers to go to
Cal and I had been at Cal as an
assistant you know years previous and I
intended to stay account for a long time
I you know I really loved the college
thing and and then yeah when the Niners
call you what do you do say no thanks um
and I had to leave some coaches behind
and that team behind kids that I
recruited but you got to do what you got
to do sometimes that sometimes it's a
no-brainer like you said Steve Mariucci
here on the Rich Eisen show let's talk
pro what why wouldn't but that's how I'm
afraid it why wouldn't Andy Reid turn to
his rookie right now with things
atrophying as they are doing right now
on the offense the start of the ball for
the chiefs Steve because because Patrick
mahomes is not better than Alex Smith
right now and an Ellen Smith you know he
started off fast and we just how much
did we talk about MVP for him and and
now they're on a skid but when you
really break it down you know he's not
as productive as he was but the blame in
football goes around and spread around
on defense and on on some injuries and
some lack of production something from
the cream hunts and the Tyriq ills of
the world for various reasons and the
the problem isn't hey let's change our
veteran quarterback out for a rookie
that doesn't solve anything now someday
Patrick mahomes will be the starter but
Alex Smith is the leader on that team
and he's Andy I don't see this make I
don't see this
happening this year I don't why can't it
be a similar situation of the one that
happened to Smith in San Francisco where
Harbaugh sat him and put in Kaepernick
and then off they went to the Super Bowl
why can't they were already doing well I
mean if Dallas Smith you know hadn't
gotten the concussion he probably would
have brought them to the to the playoffs
as well and so you know III don't I
don't see a young rookie that hasn't
practiced much at all making this kind
of change for a team sparking them Alex
Smith is their captain he's their leader
I mean it would it could potentially end
up like like the bills you take away
Tyrod Taylor who was the captain right
and all of a sudden you try to make a
change because you think a young guys
got potential and it could be it could
blow up in your face and and so you just
keep riding the horse that got you there
Kansas City is still going to make the
playoffs they got to get some other
things fixed though you think though
Steve because here come the Los Angeles
chargers we saw what happened on
Thanksgiving the charges are playing
much better than the Chiefs right now
they've got him on NFL Network by the
way we've got that game week 16 on a
Saturday you know yeah so I know in
Kansas City's got a lot of games at home
but they just they just lost to a bills
team that had given up a combined a
hundred points to two weeks before they
only scored once I don't it wasn't
pretty but the Chiefs you know they're
got the Jets your jets and they can they
can beat the Jets then they have Oakland
at home and Oakland and so up and down
you never know what you're going to get
and then like you said the charger game
in Kansas City is going to be huge then
the Chiefs can beat Miami and then
Denver what happened to Denver what did
they fall off the off the map and so the
Chiefs can win enough games to be a
playoff team a smooch the poll question
Brockman here on the Rich Eisen show all
right mooch one of these five teams in
the NFC will miss the playoffs and this
is it definite because of the fact that
there's not enough chairs for all of
them in the musical chairs here yeah
what you which one misses in the NFC
Rams Seahawks Falcons Panthers Saints
Seahawks possibly the Seahawks because
let's take a look in here what they do
they you know they have Philadelphia
next there's not a good game
to get healthy in the Seahawks on this
they have the legion of boot the engine
of the bus yes and then they have to go
to Jacksonville that's a long trip
that's as far of a trip as any NFL team
has to travel from Seattle to
Jacksonville your ankles are all swollen
from that flight and that's and they're
playing the defense and then they play
the Rams come on the Rams are good and
then at Dallas they get Zeke back and
that place is going to be hopping over
there and so I just think it's you know
for the teams you gave me the a the Rams
are legit mass they're not going
anywhere and the Saints are really good
too all of their losses are to division
leaders so it looks like the Seahawks
could be the odd ball out and I've got
Case Keenum coming up an hour - why do
you think Zimmer just doesn't come out
and rip the band-aid off and just say
he's my guy the rest of the year let's
have it let's let's end this shot Teddy
next year you know he's probably hoping
for that and you know but he just
doesn't want to he doesn't want to say
that I don't know he's just kind of
watching it go and just leave well
enough alone don't say anything that's
gonna be written in the papers or
discussed or controversial or anything
just to keep you know keep playing the
kid what a story that is you know I'm
trying to I'm trying to watch this thing
a little bit rich think about it think
about it
this guy was undrafted write Case Keenum
undrafted guy that was a backup and I
got to check the ages but and then he
could take his team deep into the
playoffs maybe when the Super Bowl in
Minneapolis is that a little bit like
Kurt Warner story undrafted guy who was
the backup and he's playing because the
guy in front of him hurt his knee all
right they both Bradford and Trent Green
both hurt their knee and then enter the
undrafted guy then and has a mirror
miraculous kind of season and and takes
them home it would be unbelievable it
sure would be and certainly if they it's
their building to man that would be kind
of cool what did you ever think that one
would go up to Jess would you ever have
that feeling last one for you that you
felt destined that one time where you
guys felt destined
to win where you just had that feeling
Steve as a coach any point in your
career Green Bay San Francisco anything
destined to win where you just felt it
like what the Vikings are on right now
it's just state they're there they're
winning games in that manner where they
give me one but it you're gonna go what
what are you talking about okay oh how
about this one you're gonna be on when I
was playing at that B northern Michigan
rich we are 110 all right my freshman
year all and ten the next listen to me
so next year we started winning and we
beat Central Michigan
they were the national champs the year
before this is there was only division 1
division 2 then we started winning and
then we were destined we were like wait
a minute we can do this too rich we won
the national championship won 13 games
it's never happened before in the
history of the world at any level in any
sport from winless to national champs so
yes we were destined to win that thing
so was isn't on that team to Steve so is
oh no he wasn't because he was the
captain of the basketball team and this
is the North Carolina last night cross
them help him look 40 points 45 points
but is it went out for spring ball
because he was you know we played we
played three sports together in high
school
so he came out for spring ball the year
before and he got he just got crushed
and and he was a running back right he's
pretty good
and I said is you you shouldn't do this
man you get hurt you're screwing your
basketball team you use the captain he
was on a basketball scholarship so so
kind of he kind of decided okay I'll
just be a one sport guy here but he was
out the spring before he could have been
on that team yeah did you see him
wearing a hoodie on the sideline the
other day you see that buddy
yeah like Belichick he's up there with a
hoodie you know yeah some days I don't
know him he calls me he calls me before
the game I call him to when he's like
sitting around in his hotel room waiting
and waiting and waiting we just call and
we just talked about saying laugh and
just like yeah you want to take the edge
off sometime says he's a nervous wreck
you know and
what he likes his team though like it's
well he should he's got a real special
one it seems brewing there in East
Lansing butyou take care we'll chat soon
ok ok that much